people need to learn to use standardized
measures for things so take me for
example
when I Drive anywhere I driving miles I
Drive in miles per hour my fuel economy
is messaging miles per gallon but of
course I don't pump fuel in my in
gallons I pump it in liters and then but
when I run anywhere so short distances I
run in kilometres and I run in
kilometers per hour so I'm using two
different systems there and any short
distances I'm measuring are going to be
in meat it's not feet right so if I'm
measuring let's say around my house for
painting I'm going to measure in square
meters so I know how much paint to buy
but then if I'm selling a house or I'm
buying a house I'm going to be looking
at the size of the house in square feet
again what who knows why British people
if I'm baking anything it's going to be
weight in grams or kilograms going into
the recipe but if I'm weighing myself is
going to be in stones and pounds but of
course a ton would for me would be a
metric tonne not an imperial time and as
I said I measure fuel in litres and most
of my liquids are measured in liters
except for coarse for beer and milk
which are in pints
so this is the kind of problem you're
going to be dealing with when you're
looking at data you're trying to
transform your data into a usable form
maybe the data is coming from different
sources none of it goes together you
need standardized units standardized
scales so we can go on and analyze it
let's think back we what we're doing is
we're trying to prepare our data into a
densest most clean format so that we can
apply modeling or machine learning or
some kind of statistical test to work
out what's going on and draw knowledge
from our data so this is going to be an
iterative process we're going to be
cleaning the data we're going to
transform the data and then we're going
to reduce for data and transforming data
is what we're going to do today so let's
imagine that you've cleaned your data so
we've got rid of as many missing
variables as possible hopefully all of
them with deleted instances and
attributes that just we're not going to
work out for us now what we're going to
try and do is we're going to try and
transform our data so that everything's
on the same scale
everything makes sense together and if
we're bringing datasets from different
places we need to also make sure what
the units are the same and everything
makes sense there's no point in trying
to use machine learning or sum or
clustering or any other mechanism to
draw knowledge from our data if our data
is is all wrong so today we're going to
be looking at census data now census
data is kind of a classic example of a
kind of data you might look at in data
analysis it's got lots of different
kinds of attributes things that are
going to need cleaning up and
transforming so we're back in our we're
going to read the census data using
census is read CSV so we've downloaded
some census data that represents samples
from the US population to begin with
we're going to read that in and you can
see that we've got 32,000 observations
and 15 attributes or variables so what
are the first timers so let's have a
quick look at just a little bit of it
and we can see the kind of thing we're
looking at so we're going to say head of
census and that's just going to produce
the first few rows so we can kind of see
the kind of data so you can see we've
got age we've got what working
classification that person has their
educational level a numerical
representation about whether they're
married or not this kind of thing so
there's a lot of different kinds of data
here some of its going to be nominal so
for example this working-class state
government private employee that's a
nominal value we might have ordinal
values or ratio values or interval
values all right we're gonna have to
delve in a little bit closer to find out
what these are now what we do to
transform this data into a usable format
for clustering or machine learning it's
going to depend on exactly what these
types of these columns are and what we
want to do with them so let's look at it
just a couple of the attributes and see
what we can do with them right we're
going to use a process called
codification the idea is that may
be things like random forests or
multi-layer perceptrons you know neural
networks aren't going to be very
amenable to putting in text-based inputs
and what we want to do is try and
replace these attributes with a
numerical score all right so let's look
at just for example of a working class
and also for example the educational
level so education now work class is the
kind of class of worker that we're
looking at here so for example a state
worker or in private sector or someone
that worked in a school or something
like this now this is a nominal value
that means there's no order to this data
at all we can't say but someone in state
is higher or lower than someone in
private and we can't also say but let's
say state is two times more or less than
some other one that makes no sense at
all so what we can't we can replace this
with numbers so let's say we could
replace private with zero and state with
one and you know self-employed with two
and so on right and that week that's
perfectly reasonable thing to do but
it's still nominal data so what we can't
do is then calculate a mean and say are
the mean is halfway between private and
public that doesn't make any sense just
because something has been replaced by a
numerical score doesn't mean that it
actually represents something that we
can quantify in that way right it's
still nominal data okay so I bet the
best advice I can give is feel free to
codify your data into easy-to-read
numbers but just bear in mind that you
can calculate the mode just like you
know the most common but you can't
calculate the median and you can't
calculate the mean another example would
be something like the educational level
now fear letting me this is ordinal data
so we could save it someone with a an
undergraduate degree it's maybe slightly
higher in terms of their the amount of
time they spent in education but someone
with a high school diploma but we don't
know exactly what the distance is and
what's the distance between let's say a
high school when a degree and then a PhD
and so on an MD and things like this we
can represent these using numbers and
probably in order right so we could say
that zero is no education and one is
sort of the end of primary school and
two is the end of high school and so on
and so forth but again it's difficult to
calculate distances between these things
we don't know what high school is two
times more than primary school and half
of a degree or something like that that
doesn't really make sense so again you
might be able to calculate a median on
this or a mode but you can't calculate
an average you can't say the average
level of
ocation it's halfway between high school
and undergraduate that doesn't make any
sense either so for any kind of
attribute that is nominal or possibly
ordinal and it's sort of represented
using text we can codify this so but
it's more amenable to things like
decision trees depending on the library
you're using right but you just have to
be careful all machine learning
algorithms will take any number you give
them and you just have to be careful
that this makes sense to do so what you
would do is you would go through your
data and you'd begin to systematically
replace appropriate attributes with
numerical versions of themselves
remembering all the time but they don't
necessarily represent true numbers you
know in a ratio or interval format so
for any text-based value we're going to
start with places and possibly with
numerical scores what about the
numerical values well they might be okay
but the issue is going to be one of
scale you might find for example in this
census data that one of the dimensions
or one of the attributes is much much
larger than another one so for example
this data set has hours per week which
is obviously going to be somewhere
between naught and maybe 60 or 70 hours
for someone that's got you know a very
strong work ethic and salary right or
salary or income or any other measure of
you know monetary gain now obviously
hours per week is going to be in the
tens and salary could be into the tens
of thousands maybe even the hundreds of
thousands those scales are not even
close to being the same that means if
you're doing clustering or machine
learning on this kind of data you're
going to be finding the salary is kind
of overbearing everything right so it's
going to be very easy for your
clustering to find differences in salary
and it's harder for it to spot
differences in hours because they're so
small in comparison right so we need to
start to bring everything onto the same
scale the more attributes you have which
is another way of saying the more
dimensions you have to your data then
the further everything is going to be
spread around if we can scale all of
these values to between sort of let's
say around 0 & 1 then everything gets
more tightly sort of controlled in the
middle and so it gets much easier to do
clustering or machine learning or any
kind of analysis we want so let's look
back at our data and see what we can do
to try and scale some of this into the
right range so we're going to look back
at the head of our data again so our
numerical values are things like the
capital gain the capital loss which I
guess Zuma bleah how much money they've
made in the loss that year
probably for normal license on some
scale and then things like the hours per
week that they work and their salary
which at this case is rate of an or less
than 50,000 so let's have a quick look
at the kind of range of values we're
looking at here so we can see if
scalings even necessary maybe we got
lucky and the person did it before they
sent us the data so we're going to apply
a function across all the columns and
we're going to calculate the range of
the data so this is going to be apply on
a census data division too so that's all
of our columns and we're going to use
the range function for this and this is
going to tell us okay so for example the
age ranges from 17 to 90 the educational
level from 1 to 16 it gives you the
range for things like nominal values as
well but they don't really make any
sense I mean working class ranges from
question mark to without pay you know is
meaningless and then so for example
capital gain ranges from zero to nearly
one hundred thousand and capital loss
from zero to four thousand and finally
the hours per week main gist from 1 to
99 so you can see that the capital gain
is many orders of magnitude larger in
scale than the hours per week we're
going to need to try and scale this data
well begin by doing to make our lives a
little bit easier
it's just focus on the numerical
attributes right so we'd have to worry
about the nominal values which we've not
codified yet we're going to select all
the columns from the data where they are
numeric so that's this line here a star
then down here so we're going to s apply
that applies over each of the fields is
it numeric and that's going to give us a
logical list that says true or false
depending on whether those columns are
numeric what we're doing here is
selecting from this list any bit of true
and then finding their name so what are
the names of a columns for the numeric
so let's have a look at just a range of
these attributes to make a life a little
bit easier so I'm gonna run this line
and so this is a simplified version of
what I was just showing you can see that
capital gain is massive compared to the
hours per week for example let's have a
look at the standard deviation the call
that the standard deviation is the
average distance from the mean so it
kinda gives us an idea of the spread of
some data like is it very tight and
everyone owns roughly the same or is it
very spread out and it's huge deviations
and the answer is there's pretty huge
deviations so the age has a standard
deviation of 13 so it obviously that
means that most people are going to be
kind of in the middle and on average
they're going to be 13 years younger or
older but you can see that things like
capital gain have a
7,000 standard deviation which is a huge
amount to give you some idea what we're
aiming for it's very common to
standardize this kind of data so but the
standard deviation is 1 right so 7,000
much too big let's plot an example but
gives you some idea of what the kind of
problem is when we have these massive
ranges so I'm going to plot here
a graph of age vs. capital games right
we know age goes between about one and a
hundred and capital gain is much much
larger so if I run this basically the
figure makes no sense at all because the
capital gain ranges from zero to one
hundred thousand and as a few people
earning right at the top scale
everything is sort of squished down the
bottom we can't see anything that's
going on there's no way of telling
whether the capital gain of an
individual is related to their age I
mean it probably is like because a
retired people people who are very young
perhaps her and slightly less we can't
really see that here because it's just
too compressed right we need to start
trying to bring these things together so
that we can perform better analysis what
we're going to do is create a new data
frame with just the numerical attribute
so we want to focus on just to make our
life a little bit easier and then we're
going to write a normalized function to
move all our data to between 0 and 1 and
we will do this per attribute so for
example if you've got some data which
goes between a minimum and a maximum and
we want to scale this data to between 0
and 1 all we need to do is first of all
take away the minimum and that's going
to move everything to be from 0 to max
minus min and then we're going to divide
by this distance here so this is max
minus min and if we divide by this
everything is going to go from 0 to 1 so
that's exactly what we're doing in this
function here we've got a function X and
it subtracts the minimum of X and then
divides by the difference between the
maximum and the minimum all right so
this is very standard so I'm going to
run this I'll let you write functions
like this and then use them in
applications over data so we're going to
calculate a normalized Census data set
which is we're going to apply over
dimension to this normalized function we
just wrote and then now if we look at
the range will see that our range is now
between 0 and 1 for all of our data
which is exactly what we want the
normalization is a perfectly good way of
handling your data if everything is
between 0 and 1 we have fewer problems
with the scale of things being way off
now some statistical techniques like PCA
that we're going to talk
video they require standardized data
that's data but it's centered around
zero it has a mean of zero and a
standard deviation of one now we can
standardize data pretty easily in the
same way actually we don't need to write
our own function for this the scale
function in our performs this force so
we're going to take the census data over
numerical attributes and we're going to
call the scale function and that's going
to take all of the attributes and center
them around their mean so that means the
mean will become close to zero and it's
going to divide them all by the standard
deviation so their standard deviation
becomes one so if we run that and then
we have a look at the mean of this data
so for example here we calculate the
mean you can see that I mean these
values are very very close to one that's
10 to the minus 17 or something like
that very very small and if we look at
the standard deviation similarly they're
all going to be 1 all right so this is
now standardized data this is a very
good thing to do if you want to use your
data in some kind of machine learning
algorithm or some kind of clustering
let's imagine now that we want to join
some data sets together so we
standardize data everything's between 0
and 1 or it's centered around 0 with a
standard deviation of 1 we've codified
some attributes what happens if we get
other data from other sources you can
imagine that census data from the US
might be a bit useful but maybe we want
census data from Spain or from the UK or
from another country can we join organs
together to get a bigger more useful
data set now the thing to think about
when you're doing this is just to make
sure that everything makes sense right
are the scales the same are they all
normalized or none of them normalized
because otherwise what you're going to
be doing is you're going to be adding
you know pay between naught and a
hundred thousand to somewhere between no
and one nothing makes any sense anymore
you're gonna wreck your data so let's
have a look at this on the census data
set we have some Spanish census data in
a very similar format to our census data
from the United States let's have a
quick look so I'm going to read the CSV
file of Spain data let's remind
ourselves of the columns that we had in
our census data from the United States
these are the numerical columns so we
have age education number capital gain
capital loss this kind of thing let's
look at the Spanish data set to see if
we can just join the two together so I'm
gonna run head Spain that's going to
give us the first few rows and you can
see that there's some of the stuff in
there is as it was before so
things like what their level of
education is whether they work in the
private sector or the public sector why
we're going to need to remove these
things to create just a numerical
attributes and the other problem is if
you look carefully you'll see that the
capital gain in the Spanish dataset is
in euros not in dollars now that's a
huge problem they don't they're not
nationally different obviously they're
on the same order of magnitude but we
don't want to be jamming capital gain in
euros next to dollars because those two
scales are not the same right so what we
need to do first is scale this data
using some kind of exchange rate so here
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a new column in Spain so given a
spain data frame we're going to say the
spain capital gain is equal to the euro
capital gain times by 1.1 3 which is the
exchange rate we're going to use now
it's quite important in this kind of
situation not just to look up the
exchange rate online you've got to
consider but this might have been
collected a while ago what was the
exchange rate when this data was
collected why these are things you're
going to have to think about so let's
run that line and let's do the same
thing for the capital loss now we're
going to keep just for numerical
attributes of our census data and of the
spanish data and we're also going to add
another column that is what country they
come from otherwise we're not going to
know so we're going to use the columbine
function to combine the census data as
numerical attributes and the native
country which in this case will be the
United States we're going to do the
exact same thing for the spain data
which will be basically exactly the same
except obviously we're also going to
have spain as the native country and
then we're going to use the roe bind
feature to just join those two tables
together now that will only work if
those two datasets have the exact same
attributes new sense is not found what
did I do wrong
so I had a typo so let's join these two
together using our bind there we go and
so our United dataset now has the
combined observations for the United
States and Spain now what you wouldn't
want to do is just join them together
and just leave it at that why you want
to perhaps have a little look at some
plots to make sure that the
distributions of the data you've just
joined together make sense for example
right thus the United States data has a
nice broad distribution of different
ages we want to make sure that the
Spanish data has that same distribution
otherwise you're kind of going to secure
your data set
so for example let's have a look at
roughly whether the levels of capital
gain are approximately the same for both
the United States and the Spanish data
set so I'm gonna use ggplot for this
we're gonna plot a bar chart where we've
color-coded United States and Spain and
you can see that broadly speaking
there's a lot in the kind of around zero
or less than 50k and then there's a few
a little bit above all right so that
looks broadly speaking the same
distribution I'm fairly happy with that
this is gonna be a judgement call when
you get your own data so I'll clear the
screen and then let's have a look at the
next plot so the next plot is going to
be capital loss versus the native
country let's make sure those
distributions are the same so it's
posting there and broadly speaking again
yes the majority are down the bottom and
then there's a few United States ones
and a couple of Spanish ones up at the
top as well again it's not a disaster
that's probably ok finally let's have a
look at ages by native country so if we
plot this we can see two very very
similar distributions you can see that
it's essentially a bell curve maybe
slightly skewed towards older
participants for the United States and
very very similar for Spain this is okay
if we hypothesized that capital gain
capital loss and salary was something to
do with your age then it would make
sense to have two data sets that you're
joining together have very similar
distributions in this regard so let's
look at one more data set from Denmark
all right so it's the same thing same
format we're gonna read the CSV and
we're going to have a look at just the
top few rows to make sure it's in the
same format so that's using a head
function and you can see actually we've
already removed the nominal and other
text attributes from here and we've just
got the numerical ones and actually also
capital gain and capital loss are
already in dollars in this data set so
we don't have to perform a conversion so
we can use our bind to put these two
things together and now we just need to
check the distributions are the same so
again we're going to put the age against
the native country and see if these
towards the same distributions and you
actually you can see this isn't looking
too good the United States and the
Spanish dataset have very similar
distributions the participants or the
people who have been polled from Denmark
are much much older on average right
this could have an effect on things like
capital gain so I wouldn't necessarily
feel comfortable just joining this data
set in without you thinking about it a
little bit more closely alright so
whenever you're joining data set like
this taking data from different sources
think carefully
to make sure that it's fair and what
you're doing is a reasonable
concatenation of datasets and actually
these are the features that power
Spotify recommender system and numerous
others so we've got things like acoustic
nurse how acoustic does it sound from
from a zero to a one
we've got instrumental nurse I'm not
convinced as a word speech enos the hat
hat to what extent is it speech or not
speech and then things like ten